[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 20
of you are subscribed so if you enjoy
the content please consider
subscribing to support the channel in
this video we're going to be discussing
harry potter
and a certain ability that he possesses
throughout the books and films
now if he will allow me to massively
overstate something
it's the fact that voldemort and harry
shared a connection it was a connection
they shared for most of harry's life
in fact it was a connection that lasted
from the year 1981
all the way to the end of the second
wizarding war when voldemort was finally
defeated
the events of the night of october 31st
were tragic it was during the first
wizarding war and voldemort was arguably
at his strongest all of his dark
endeavors had gone rather
successfully for him and he had amassed
quite the legion of followers it was on
this fateful night that voldemort
stumbled into the potter's humble home
in godric's hollow seeking out the
potters in an attempt to stop civil
trollony's
prophecy from coming true he traveled
there with one goal in mind
killed a boy kill harry potter when he
entered the potter residence
his first obstacle was james potter who
voldemort made quick work of
next he began making his way towards
lily and baby harry
however what i'm sure voldemort didn't
expect that night was that he
would be defeated voldemort asked lilly
to step aside
offering to spare her life if she would
allow him to have harry
unsurprisingly she refused voldemort's
offer and was subsequently murdered by
his killing curse
next voldemort advanced towards harry
letting out one final avada kadavra for
the night
with the hopes of putting an end to the
boy however what voldemort didn't know
was that lily had placed a loving
sacrifice on harry an ancient and
powerful form of magical protection
when voldemort used to vada kadavra it
instantly rebounded and was deflected
back at him
the rebounding curse effectively split
voldemort's soul but because his body
was gone
destroyed by the curse the soul fragment
could not be encased to complete the
horcrux creation
part of horcrux creation involves an
encasing spell
which actually puts the soul outside of
the body hidden to a physical object
because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment it latched itself
to harry
for this reason harry contained
voldemort's soul fragment
but was never possessed by it if we look
at voldemort's horcruxes
we know that they are often
characteristically similar to voldemort
because they contain parts of his soul
they are evil objects that you
generally want to stay away from however
harry was sort of an exception
he wasn't a traditional horcrux and
didn't get all of the characteristics
for horcrux
but he certainly got some one of the
most notable abilities at harry got
after voldemort's murder attempt
was the ability to speak parcel tongue a
parcel math
if you didn't know already a parcel
mouth is one who is able to speak
parcel tongue the language of snakes
it's a hereditary trait that is passed
on
through descendants of salazar slytherin
which voldemort happened to be
it's widely accepted that salazar was
the original pastor mouth
but others have speculated that it may
in fact have been
herpo defaul the original horcrux
creator
who lived before salazar's slitherings
era either way
descendants of salazar himself carry
this trait
which is probably why the connection is
so strong between southern house and
snakes
it's their house emblem after all harry
first discovers that he's able to speak
to snakes in the zoo
in a philosopher's stone at that point
in time he was entirely ignorant to
magic
in its entirety and so everything that
was happening to him
was shocking enough however it is only
later on that harry actually discovers
that being a pastor mouth is quite a
unique trait you see
when he speaks parcel tongue and speaks
to snakes to an outside observer
he's speaking the language of snakes but
to harry
all he hears is himself speaking
normally when he finally finds out that
it's a unique ability
he's quite surprised from the chamber of
secrets
so said harry i bet loads of people here
can do it
oh no they can't said ron it's not a
very common gift
harry this is bad and while the ability
to speak to snakes
being a parcel tongue isn't innately bad
there's definitely a certain amount of
stigma
surrounding it salazar slytherin the man
most commonly associated with parcel
tongue
was a strong proponent of having only
pure blood students at hogwarts
this philosophy was not particularly
welcomed by hogwarts which led to his
eventual ousting
however it also led to salazar's
creation of the chamber of secrets
a secret chamber in the school housing a
basilisk
intended to purge the school of
muggle-borns and bloods
harry wasn't sure what made him do it he
wasn't even aware of deciding to do it
all he knew was that his legs were
carrying him forward so he was on the
casters and that he had shouted stupidly
at the snake
leave him and miraculously inexplicably
the snake slumped to the floor docile as
a thick black garden hose
its eyes now unharry harry felt the fear
drain out of him
he knew the snake wouldn't attack anyone
now though how he knew it
he couldn't have explained when it was
discovered that harry could speak parcel
tongue
he was immediately judged by the student
body and it was the general consensus
among students
that harry was responsible for opening
the chamber in that same year
when rita skeeter found out about
harry's ability she told the whole world
which didn't help the public opinion of
harry even ron
harry's best friend found it to be
creepy and it turns out that parcel
tongue
though most commonly a hereditary trait
can actually be learned as well
in an interview rowling revealed that
albus dumbledore had been able to master
parcel tongue over the course of his
life
and could understand it well he was just
unable to speak it
aloud why albus learned it in the first
place is unclear
but he was a man of many talents who
really didn't set limitations on himself
so i'm really not too surprised anyway
back to harry
he could speak parseltongue for most of
his life and he was tied to voldemort
for a very long time
because voldemort's soul fragment lived
inside of him
this same soul fragment was responsible
for harry's ability to speak parcel
tongue
so when voldemort died and the soul
fragment inside of harry was gone
did it result in harry losing his
ability to speak to snakes
on pottermore this is addressed harry
being an accidental horcrux
meant he was bound to voldemort in so
many ways just like voldemort was bound
to serpents
not only could harry speak the language
of the snake but could see through the
eyes of nagini
another of voldemort horcruxes as it
turned out
once the part of voldemort saw that
dwelt inside harry was destroyed
however harry discovered he was no
longer a parcel mouth
an added bonus of voldemort's demise
however
just because harry was no longer a part
of mouth it doesn't mean that he didn't
have any retained knowledge
of parcel tongue a parcel mouth
generally refers to someone who can
speak the language where apostle tongue
is a language itself
dumbledore for example knew the language
but couldn't speak it
what this tells me is that even though
harry lost the ability to
speak parcel tongue he probably still
had a pretty good understanding of it
and i expected he could probably still
understand what snakes were saying to
him
even if he couldn't talk back there's no
reason that harry would suddenly forget
some of the words that he uttered in
pasta tongue
like open which he used on many
occasions
so harry can no longer speak it fair
enough looks like this is addressed
but can he still understand it in my
opinion
most likely what do you guys think
do you think that harry lost it all
together or are you with me in thinking
that he can still understand it
but just can't speak it let me know down
in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
hurry
you